I spoke to Jeremy Corbyn last weekend
and he said that if no deal has been
agreed then the Prime Minister must obey
the law he must send the letter to the
EU and request that extension
well that's happened be happy no really
because he's also sent another letter
hasn't he which seems to be well I think
he may well be in contempt of parliament
all the courts themselves because he's
clearly trying to undermine the first
letter and not signing the letter yet
he's behaving a bit like a sport brat
Parliament made a decision he should
abide by it and this idea that you send
another letter contradicting the first I
think it flies in the face of what both
Parliament and the courts have decided
it isn't all that stuff just theatre you
know whether or not he signed it whether
or not other things I mean he has sent
the letter has many you seem to have
accepted it you know to a certain extent
it is theatre but at the same time it
does Drive at the heart of darkness E
where a Prime Minister has to abide by
the law and if you're as a prime
minister trying to undermine a decision
made by Parliament that flies in the
face of actually that concept of abiding
by the law so yes it is a bit of theatre
but at the same time there is something
fundamental here as well so you think it
could go as far as going to the court it
may well be others will decide that
matter but a number of lawyers have
already commented that this is seeking
to undermine a decision of Parliament
and therefore flies as I say flies in
the face of bird palm and court
decisions well some of our view is we're
thinking was they they were thought that
you know the Prime Minister only had to
ask for an extension if there wasn't a
deal if you fail to get a deal yeah well
there is now a deal and MPs effectively
decided not to vote on it know what MP's
did on Saturday and remember this has
all been set up for dramatic effect and
political effect by the prime minister
these deadlines unnecessary deadlines
all Parliament agreed on Saturday was
before we make a decision can we just
see the legislative proposals in detail
like any other piece of legislation like
any other law we're considering let us
have the bill and let's consider that
bill properly but that's not too much to
ask for when you're talking about
legislation that will affect the future
of our economy that's generation it's
not just the Prime Minister setting the
deadlines is it the October 31st
deadline was the one that was agreed by
the European Union and the deadline of
the 19th was the one that was agreed by
MPs well
disrespect the 19th was the proposal by
the prime minister himself and this idea
of Super Saturday as far as I can see
was simply for theatrical effect what we
said to him on Saturday
yesterday was look we need the bill
before us like we would consider any
other but even minor amendments to the
law we consider through legislation in
that way we say and bring it back next
week and that's considerate and you know
he might even meet the deadline of the
31st of October if we would go through a
proper parliamentary process so other
any chance is there any chance that
Labour will back the deal next week then
we will when the bill comes forward what
we'll try to do as in the normal way put
amendments to that bill and see whether
or not we can ensure that it meets the
criteria that we've set out the problem
that we've got is this is becoming quite
a fundamental choice about the future of
our economy do we do we want to go down
the Boris Johnson proposals of diverging
from our major trading partner and
deregulate in our economy undermining
workers rights consumer and
environmental rights no we don't so what
we'll try and do is of course trying to
mend that legislation and see if we can
get agreement in Parliament you say that
it undermines workers rights and but
there's nothing that actually mentions
workers rights you know in the actual
agreement though the only way that as
you say workers rights could be
undermined is if that's voted for by
Parliament which is how a democracy well
what's interesting is that we have
guarantees we had guarantees under
tourism a for actually these this level
playing field that we have want between
US and Europe on workers rights consumer
environmental rights would be contained
within the international treaty but the
bill itself and what we got from Boris
Johnson was taking it out of the treaty
and therefore removing those protections
that we had and this is a matter this is
a matter of trust can we trust Boris
Johnson with employment consumer
environmental rights well he's just
betrayed the consider this is a
conservative and unionist prime minister
who's just betrayed his partners the DUP
of course we can't trust him I mean what
they would say is that they've managed
to get a veto or a unilateral exit
mechanism for Northern Ireland which is
something that the new EU would never
say they would they've managed to
protect the fact that they won't have a
hard border on the island bathroom not
far from me to speak on behalf the DUP
but I listened to what they said yes
they were promised by boss Johnson in
his own words
no border down the Irish trip down the
Irish Sea that's happening they were
promised that he would abide by the
processes of Good Friday Agreement the
process he's put forward undermines the
Good Friday Agreement in that way this
is the DUP talking not me he's betrayed
his own electoral partners how can we
trust him on anything what would you do
to labor in peace who defy what the
leadership says and support the deal
well the whips will deal with them in
the normal way I've always well in
always conversation or discussion and
then they'll take appropriate action and
thank goodness I'm not the chief whip
I've got enough on my plate as Shadow
Chancellor but jeremy corbyn's decision
is far better well it's the chief whip
reporting to the leader I've always I've
always said there has to be a respectful
whip on a number of these things where
we take into account people's views and
that's what we've done so far people
yesterday I think what was interesting
was people are honestly expressing their
views and they will over the process of
this legislation and that's the best way
forward and I say that across all
parties as well so would you call on you
MPs on your own side labor supporters to
back off some of the criticism that
we've seen levelled at people such as
Caroline Flint such as many people have
to be listened to
Melanie and Caroline have made detailed
criticisms of the proposals themselves
and they've also put forward their own
ideas about how it can be proved people
have to be listened to and I think that
applies across all political parties
there's even this morning there's a
number of conservatives who may have
voted with the prime minister on
Saturday but are deeply concerned about
the naturist legislation and I just give
you one example Philip Hammond stood up
in Parliament and said he's really
worried that we're still in a situation
whereby the government couldn't
negotiate in a very limited time for a
free trade agreement and yet then still
hang over us the prospect there were no
deal after that child months of time
after the end of the transition period
that's a real worry for a number of
conservative MPs as well as Labour MP so
what do you think needs to happen next
then what's Labour's planck's it's very
easy isn't it to criticize we what's the
way through but we understand the
frustration of people we're all
frustrated we want to sort this thing
out
the legislate we will say to the
government don't it's pointless bring
another meaningful vote that's just a
political stunt and I'm not even sure if
the I'm not important to have a vote on
the deal that's been struck by the EU
and we haven't vote on the deal on that
when you see the legislation until you
see the legislation you don't know the
detail and as someone said yes in the
debate the devil is in the detail all
we've got at the moment is some of the
elements of the agreement we haven't got
that translated into detailed
legislation that's how we enact
legislate that how we make laws in this
country you don't do on the basis of few
pages of you know writing that a script
that were put these happen right okay
what I'm saying to the government is
pointless bringing the meaningful vote
again we've had one debate on I'm not
even sure the speaker will allow bring
the legislation forward and let's do the
real parliamentary process of
scrutinizing that legislation and yes
we'll be moving amendments and see
whether or not we can get some form of
agreement through the House of Commons
that's then acceptable
are you gonna be moving an amendment for
a second referendum well that will
almost inevitably come up there was an
amendment tabled on Saturday we've
always said actually that the people
decide I mean it's different if it will
never be often come up well after yeah
often the tactical choice on this is
sometimes it's better coming from a
group of MPs from the back benches where
you can get cross party agreement and we
back can remember we've spoken about
this on your program some months ago we
backed the Kyle Wilson amendment which
came from the back benches which some
cross-party support though I think
inevitably that will come up but we've
always said on a deal like this if Boris
Johnson is confident about this deal go
back to the people with it you see the
fact that you say that you will
inevitably come up it doesn't sound like
labour will put it forward you can't
just wonder you can't help but wonder
you know you were there on the people's
boat March yesterday but so far labour
is effectively chickened out or bring
forward a push for a second referendum
when I spoke Jeremy Corbyn last weekend
he said he couldn't even tell me how he
would campaign if there was a second
referendum leave or remain I mean are
you at risk here if not seeming as if
you're a party wholly behind a second
referendum that you're falling through
the cracks and practice no not at all we
voted for Carl Wilson amendment before
which called for a second referendum it
was raised again on
sadly but not moved I'm sure it will be
moved tactically these things are often
better moved from the back benches we
can secure cross-party support and where
you're not alienating people purely and
simply because it's the leader of the
Opposition moving it what we've said is
Boris Johnson should take this deal back
to the people we've also said you know
we want a general election - and in that
general election we've said we would
negotiate a sensible option for brexit
and they would put that before the
people so we're not averse our going
back to the people quite the reverse we
want the people to have the final say
you've been relatively quick to move
behind the idea of a second referendum
Jeremy Corbyn perhaps has taken a little
bit longer to get to that point and I
just wanted to have a look at a quote a
video if you like that with social
circulating on social media from 2013
it's you and Jeremy Corbyn you're at a
fringe event a Labour representative
representation committee fringe event
which is a socialist group in labour and
this is something that Jeremy Corbyn
said at that time he said to you it's
quite helpful to have you around to
explain what I'm supporting something
when it isn't obvious to me as to why we
should be but I'm sure there's a good
reason behind it and you do it so well
is that what's happened with a second
referendum if you've been around how you
was planning to Jeremy Corbyn why he
means I remember I wrote he was pulling
my leg it was a joke you can see that
there is time I think what happened was
I think if I remember rightly on this
I'd interrupted him whilst he was
speaking about something and he was
joking that way but you know we work
together with a close partnership we've
worked together for 40 years and
sometimes we will agree sometimes will
disagree but we'll always support one
another and that's what we always do and
when he thinks I'm going off the rails
does he think you go off the rails and
breaks it a little bit no not at all no
we've we've followed consistently they
party policy from the conference before
last and we've gone through that
sequence of events and that's where we
are I mean they're happy reports that
there's been a bit of a power struggle
within the Labour plan well this always
comes up on on policy news on the second
referendum on staffing issues and that
you were the winner you're the one
taking back control this comes up every
autumn it's like a hardy perennial
usually what in one week last year I
think it was it was I was organizing a
coup
and then within the same week I was
holding Jeremy Corbyn hostage not
unfortunately not Theresa
it is farcical will we work together
we'll never be divided we always back
each other up
we'll have disagreements on different
matters but we'll always come to a
conclusion that we we support each other
okay and what do you think should come
first a second referendum well if we're
dealing with this bill and what we're
saying to boss Johnson you should put it
to the people but what we're saying is
it would be better to have a general
election we think we we would argue for
a general election in which we could put
forward our proposals to negotiate a
sensible deal brexit deal but would have
a remain option as well and they would
go back to the people we can't do that
and a limited period of time as well and
get this matter over with once and for
all so you know as the let one amendment
has gone through as the letter has been
sent no deal does appear to be off the
table at least further indeed does that
mean that if the government brought
forward a motion to try and trigger a
general election would labor bakit well
we want to have absolutely sure no
deal's off the agenda and we're not sure
that yet let's see the legislation let's
see what we can do at this legislation
and how far we can move in there mints
and secure our economy look people think
this is all about Parma Tory process
this isn't what this is about it's a
fundamental choice about the future of
our country do we want to go down with
an economy in which Boris Johnson wants
us to diverge from our major market and
deregulate our economy what does the
regulation that gets repond right well
let's see what deregulation means this
is how important it is for us it means
undermining workers rights going along
the American economic model you know
well eight to ten days annual leave
individual contracts undermining this
Thunder well undermining basic trading
rights will have the protections now we
can't trust Boris Johnson with our
economy in that way but also it means
undermine our consumer protections and
yes I think undermined our environmental
protection that's what this battle is
all about it isn't some romantic view of
Europe or anything like that this is
about the future of our economy and the
living standards of our people just
quickly you and we're talking about an
election you say you want an election if
Labour loses that election sure Jeremy
Corbyn stand down well that would be a
decision for Jeremy eivol
I've said in the past you know usually
when they've actually stand down all the
rest of it that'll be a decision for
Jeremy I think there's no prospect of us
losing that election I think a little
bit from what you said - no that's all
right well they all jointly said the
usual thing would be yes that's right I
vote I also say which wasn't included in
the clips or the reports that we're
going to win that election will have a
majority Labour government which will
enable us to build upon that
well our ideas about how we want to
transform our society and we will when
do you want election to be well as soon
as we possibly can I like well we'll see
we'll see what happens over this next
week or so I'd like to get rid of this
government as soon as possible so that
we can start rebuilding our country